we are told the square below represents
one hole so this big square here
represents a hole express the shaded
area as both a fraction and a decimal so
let's see we've taken the hole and we've
divided it into 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
equal sections each of these columns or
each of these tall rectangles represent
1/10 of the hole because there are 10
equal sections that it has been split
into so each of these is 1/10 and let's
see we have filled in one two three four
five six of those tenths so if I wanted
to represent it as a fraction I would
say this is six tenths and if I were to
represent it as a decimal I would say
okay well I have zero 1s and I have six
tenths so as a decimal it is 0.6 let's
do a couple more of these examples so
let's say so okay oh look at that now I
have let's see the big square represents
one hole express the shade areas both a
fraction and a decimal so what's going
on over here so I have 10 or Rose and in
each row I have 10 squares so 10 times
10 I'm going to us has 100 squares in it
so I've divided my hole into 100 equal
sections so each of these little squares
is one hundredths so here I have shaded
in 1 2 3 4 5 out of the hundred
hundredths or I could say I have five
hundredths right over here so as a
fraction I could write this as five
hundredths and as a decimal I could say
well I have no ones I have no tents and
I have five hundredths let's do a couple
more examples of this so let's say that
I want to let's see it says Express the
location of the point on the number line
is both a fraction and a decimal all
right so let's think about it so this is
2/10 this is 3/10 and you see the zero
tenths 110 or
zero 1/10 2/10 3/10 and before each but
or between each tenth they've split it
into 10 equal sections 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10
so each of these each of these little
hash marks represent one hundredth so
one way you could view this is we're at
two tenths so we have two tenths and
then we're going to have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
hundredths so we could view this point
as 2 tenths and 7 hundredths so actually
let me write it as a decimal first so we
have 2 tenths and we have 7 hundredths
now another way to think about this is
we have 27 hundredths you can count them
remember each of these is one hundredths
so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 27
hundredths and most people when they see
this number they won't say two tenths
and seven hundredths they'll just say 27
hundredths well how do you write 27
hundredths as a fraction well it's 27
hundredths 27 over over 100
let's do I don't was I'm kind of in the
mood let's do one more of these the big
square represents one whole express the
shaded areas both a fraction and a
decimal so we've already seen there's a
hundred of these the whole is put into a
hundred small equal smaller sections so
each of these small squares is a hundred
and so how many hundredths do we have
shaded in so this is going to be ten
hundredths 20 hundredths 21 hundredths
so as a fraction I'd write that is 21
hundredths now you could there's a
couple of ways to think about it if
you're if we're familiar with it already
we'd say okay look two tenths is the
same thing as 20 hundredths so it's
going to be two tenths and one
hundredths or twenty-one hundredths
another way to think about it is this
first row right over here that's 1/10
then this next one is a 10
so you have two tenths and then you have
a hundred over here so any way you want
to think about it this is twenty one
hundredths or two tenths and one
hundredths